Great weather we're having!
Awesome job!
You're a tremendous athlete!
Compliments, right?
Well, maybe.
Depending on the attitude and tone of voice behind these lines,...
...they very well may be compliments.
They may also be, though, pointed and attacking lines.
This slight change of attitude behind the lines reveals what we call "verbal irony."
So when someone says, "Great weather we're having,"...
...it is quite possible that person really means that...
...if the sun is shining, the birds are singing and the wind is calm.
But if the weather is horrible, the clouds are looming and the wind is a raging tempest,...
...and someone says, "Great weather we're having,"...
...he probably doesn't actually mean that.
He probably means that the weather is horrible,...
...but he has said the opposite.
This is verbal irony:...
...when the speaker says the opposite of what he means.
I know what you're thinking.
Isn't this sarcasm?
Isn't the speaker being sarcastic?
Yes.
When a speaker says the opposite of what he means, that is verbal irony.
When the speaker then goes the step farther to mean the opposite of what he says...
...and seeks to be a little pointed and mean, like he's making fun of something,...
...then you have sarcasm.